yeah what's your prediction for the end
state of all of this
activism is it inherently
self-contradictory and splintered into
groups that don't agree
to the point where it's going to eat its
own tail it is self-contradictory but it
embraces the contradictions and that's
why it's impossible to reason with it
and that goes right back to the
postmodernist as well and you know
someone like derek
who was very playful uh and
self-contradictory so often deliberately
so and that that means that
actually it's sort of built into their
system it doesn't matter that they have
contradictory thoughts and they can hold
those contradictory thoughts at the same
time
uh it it really doesn't you know it
doesn't matter that they will say
uh that that uh well let's give the
example of the
to go back to the trans example they say
gender is completely a social construct
except for trans people who are born in
the wrong body
it doesn't matter that that can't that
doesn't make any sense because they just
they can do that whereas everyone else
relies on the idea of rationality and
rational thought but the problem is that
they would perceive that to be a sort of
heterosexual patriarchal construct
so you know you're back to square one so
what's what's going to happen we
we roll this forward what's the end
state what do you see look into the
crystal ball
andrew and tell us what you said yeah
you know whenever i do this i get it
wrong though
well there's a lot at stake so i think
well ultimately it's going to go one one
of two ways isn't it other
i i can't envisage that this can just
rumble on as it is
anymore i think there were a lot of
people who were sort of saying before
the explosion this year
of of of the culture war there were a
lot of people who were just saying this
will always be the way
there will always be the sort of extreme
culture warriors pushing their agenda
and most people will just gently push
back and
and we'll constantly be having these
these spats and these disputes
i don't think we can say that anymore i
think one side is going to have to win
out
uh so if the if the culture warriors
went out if the social justice left
or the identitarian left or whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call them win
out we will be living in a under a form
of authoritarianism
right where people are not allowed to
say certain things
will literally be arrested for saying
the wrong thing and
and it will be uh very scary and
dangerous education will be decolonized
to the point where it won't mean
anything anymore uh artifacts from the
past
monuments in the past a recognition of
history will be swept away
um and we're already seeing that
happening but not
as i say not in a crisis point you know
it's important not to inflate these
things you know i don't agree with mobs
deciding which statues stay up and which
don't right but ultimately that statue
of
edward colston you know i don't think
they should have been able to just
arbitrarily decide and tear it down
but it doesn't amount to a crisis it
doesn't no matter
you know we're not talking about as you
said the orwellian principle of
literally revising history
throwing things down the memory hole yet
and that's the qualifier is that the
problem is that these are the seeds of
that
and you have to be vigilant against this
stuff and particularly when it comes to
free speech
you have to be incredibly vigilant it's
not something that that is the default
of any given society it's something that
has to be fought for
with each successive generation and
people need to be reminded of the
validity of it and the importance of it
um
so i think if for instance a government
were to get in that was
uh identity obsessed as the current
labour party
is um but they had maybe a more zealous
identitarian leader uh i mean kyostama
wouldn't be that person
as it happens i know he sort of toys
with it a little bit but he wouldn't be
that sort of extreme zealot uh
identitarian type
if you had a government like that then
you have a very dangerous situation and
you have a society that is going to go
backwards very very
quickly um or the alternative is that we
we reached the point where
what i'm hoping is in about 15 20 years
time
we will have restored the idea of
liberal values and free speech and
everyone will just go back to just
accepting yes that's
that's the default that's what we should
be having and they'll almost
look back at these years as like what
happened there there was a kind of
hysteria there was a kind of weird
mania that happened and and they'll
probably say but it was it wasn't really
a big deal was it because it just sort
of went away and it was fine
but of course it only it only went away
because people like us are pushing back
against it but we will be considered the
nut cases like why are we even worried
about it
just win yeah i think that's what's
gonna i think i fear
that's what's gonna happen i think i
think that that
really um dovetails quite nicely with
something i've been thinking about this
year which is
been reading a lot of existential
threats and existential risk work like
toby odds which is
what prompted my concern to do with the
academics and the low-hanging fruit and
the tick-tock
and um this year we got a pandemic
it's been anyone who's looked at
existential risk or anything coming out
of the future of humanities institute
knew that this is one of the big ones
the control problem for artificial
general intelligence is another one of
them but we got delivered
touchwood we got delivered such a like
piss weak pathogen the mortality rate on
it
it's just not the incubation period and
the transmit ability
are all okay ish the r number could be
you know if i was designing it
one to end the human race the our number
might be a little bit higher and
the incubation period where you're
asymptomatic also might be a little bit
longer
um but we got delivered here's a here's
the beta test here's the demo
exactly i know what you mean what
happens and maybe
this is the ideological conceptual
equivalent where people are trying to
hijack
all of the institutions that mean the
most like um education like chil
ch children education higher education
the arts
popular culture politics all of that
stuff but they did it
with the marxists that some people
speculate are the conspiratorial pushers
of this that are in the background that
are the trojan horse that this
particular
um ideology is trying to deliver they
chose
they got on the wrong horse they chose
to get into the wrong thing and it was
just so inherently ridiculous
that we are now inoculated in the future
moving forward maybe
i hope so i think you might there might
be something to that insofar as
i suppose the analogy is if if we have a
much more serious pandemic we'll be
better prepared for
it because we've lived through this and
similarly with the social justice stuff
maybe i don't know a bit but but the but
the problem is that they're pretty well
ingrained
in these institutions now that if this
isn't something it feels like it's just
happened overnight
but it hasn't it's been percolating for
decades yeah so so it's
it is about and again i don't think the
responses
do we do we have a long march through
the institutions the other way do the
liberals
find a way to infiltrate um i i don't
know if that's the right approach either
but it's
it's gonna take an awful lot to undo but
yes i think that
that could be the case that that enough
people are now pushing back on this
stuff
uh that that when the big wave comes
maybe we'll
i think so we'll be less tolerant of it
yeah precisely you know because actually
this has only really happened
not so much because of the screaming
activists it's not really them it's not
the people with pink hair screeching and
setting off fire alarms
it's the people capitulating to them
that's the problem you see what should
happen
let's give an example the radar the
royal academy of dramatic art
uh issued a statement saying that they
are systemically racist and
institutional as everyone is saying at
the moment
which begs the question why would anyone
want to go there you know i'm not i
i'm going to support a racist
institution i really love the fact that
princeton made that confession and was
then investigated by the department of
education because racism is illegal by
the way
so you know i don't trust it i don't
trust it when i see companies saying
yeah we're working hard to dismantle our
white supremacy i'm like
why are you telling me you're a white
supremacist organization you don't
really
you don't sainsbury's right if
sainsbury's is white supremacist i'm
going to waitrose
i'm just not having this like but you
were educated at oxford andrew so it
would only
ever be between waitrose and marx and
spencer's right i know i'm
quite like little what little has good
wines by the way don't let anyone tell
you different
fine so listen i i i would suggest and
because they don't really mean it do
they
there's no way that sainsbury's think
they're a racist organization of course
they don't mean that
so don't say it you utter idiots don't
say it right
so i can't remember what what my train
of thought on this was
i can't even remember right so here's
the example right yeah so radha's
statement that they were and then of
course this
this enabled all of these crazy students
and not all of them just a few
to write a hundred page document of
demands
saying what how they need to decolonize
radar 100 pages i'm not kidding right
it's online you can you can feel it it
is the most insane
unhinged document i've seen for an awful
long time it is so entitled
it reeks of entitlement it's like we we
get to decide absolutely everything we
believe in these power structures
everything is racist you're
institutionally racist everything you
know it's absolutely insane it's like
the it's like the ravings of a madman
it's like jack nicholson in the shining
writing all those pages of the same
sentence over and over again because
that's what it is it's the same demand
phrased in different ways a million
[ __ ] times so there's that going on
right and
the response to that should have been
that the heads of radar should have said
thank you for your concerns you're
perfectly free to leave because we're
not going to capitulate to your demands
bye bye
bye go and do your crazy [ __ ] elsewhere
right because we've got to teach people
how to play yago or whatever right so
that's what people should be doing right
but what they don't what they do is they
say oh absolutely they bow down they say
because they don't want
they don't want the scandal they don't
want the twitter storm they don't want
so they capitulate they capitulate so
capitulation is the problem
not the activists themselves because the
activists are always a minority there's
not many of them but now they know they
can get their way
just by so they're like toddlers if you
screech enough they get their way right
you've got to be disciplined with
toddlers
you've got to smack them around the head
and say no actually no don't don't see
that okay
i could get in trouble for that i know
i'm going to stick back i'm going to get
andy
andy node final beat up your children
beat them up
hit them yeah i'm sticking with that hit
them with
uh anti-racist baby hit them with auntie
a copy of anti-racist baby that's
because it's hard yeah it's a thick
bored book you could do some real damage
to it please
do not obviously we're joking